very exciting we have two of the
funniest people who ever made some of
the bestest and funniest movies ever and
one of them just directed the other in
the new HBO documentary Albert Brooks
defending my life please welcome Albert
Brooks and Rob
Reiner there they
are there's the sunshine boys how are
youe how are you you're looking very
Spas I'm uh
I'm I'm I'm so celt or whatever the celt
that's not a Jewish word there's
noing you're fing that's what I is a
hospital word it's four months to live I
see paent in 208 is
felt anyway but it's been a I mean I've
wanted you here for the longest time you
I don't get to see enough but it's
always a pleasure when you're here um
thank you for bringing him for doing
this what am I a
dog he's my service
animal okay fun to look out the window
and I
I I always knew you guys were friends
until I saw this documentary I didn't
know I know you went back I didn't know
what you go way way back like high
school yes SCH we met in high school yes
oh my God yeah and we became instant
friends uh we met it was a class I I
think we were like 16 17 at the time 16
it was it remains one of the most
embarrassing moments of my life
because so it was a class the first day
you stand up you introduce yourself now
I was given the name Albert Einstein and
still using it at the time oh really
except I didn't like it in high school I
had to use Al because I didn't want
people to you know confuse him with
I mean
I now people would say you know why did
they name me Albert Einstein well Jesus
Christ was taken that
was
so so I I stood up and I said my name is
Al Einstein I'm from Los Angeles and
Rob's way in the back and then 40 other
people and then he stands up in the back
and I don't I just hear Rob from New
York I never heard any last name so
after the class I choose to come up to
him you're from New York huh now two
weeks earlier I went to a museum of
broadcasting just because I loved it and
I met Carl Riner I shook his hand I said
to him uh so what are you doing from New
York what does your dad do Rob goes he's
a writer I don't know why bill but I
said I Know Carl
Riner and
and I said so do
I and he said that's my dad and I said
I'm a stupid
but your dad thought he was like
the funniest kid even I I not just the
funniest kid he thought he was the
funniest person I mean Albert at 16 was
a prodigy he could make my dad Mel
Brooks people of the highest level in
comedy make them laugh so that I heard
that in the documentary and I'm curious
if you could just give me one instance
of that that I can picture a 16-year-old
what did you say what did you do that
made these comedy Lions laugh well I did
a bit ones from him and Mel and a lot of
other comedians a bit Yeah well he and
he came I would come over to their house
and do bits on the top of his head and
not he didn't plan it and he just came
up and he said you know I I'm I i' I've
got this thing I'm the I'm the greatest
escape artist in the world I can get out
of anything and so we took a a napkin
and he says tie my hands up and I draped
the napkin over his hands he said that's
good enough I I can't get out of I can't
get out of that and then he he took a a
tissue and he stuffed it in his mouth
and he said okay and then he went behind
a curtain and he said he's going to get
out from behind a curtain with this and
we hear from behind the curtain it's
rustling we're hearing I can't breathe I
can't breathe I free open the we open
the curtain and he flies out he says
take it out take it out untie me and we
untied him and my father was screaming
hysterically the worst escape
artist so
you so you were not bad for 15 noing he
was he was he was a genius and is a
genius right and and wound up doing your
standup career the same way even on
television right not really thinking
about it before you well I I would I
would work it out by my myself at home
and then I would go down and I would do
National Television I never went to a
club ever until I had done like five
years of national television yeah so I
never tried out anything and it was it
was fine it it worked out yeah I mean
Chris Rock says in the documentary says
the the idea of somebody going on
national television and not even trying
it out not even seeing if it would work
that's what he did he did it all the
time he went on Carson 30 times and he
just tried up new stuff and so by the
time you graduated high school you were
Fast Friends yeah yeah yeah yeah and
then summer St together and then what
was the I'm curious about the time like
before you were married when you were
just to you know well we had a house we
had a house we room together after we
had a house uh up in off Benedict Canyon
it had two entrances there was one below
where Albert was and then there was one
above it like a duplex we each had our
own phones and whenever I brought a girl
over uh you know we'd uh you know have
our
fun in the
bedroom he mean he means he and the girl
yeah I understand no it's HBO we can say
anything we're in the yeah we're having
we're making love up upstairs making
love you can still say okay we
we
and and the minute the minute we were
done the phone would ring and I pick it
up and it would be Albert and he'd say
are you finished
yet and I'd say yes now let me tell you
something he said do you want to go get
something to eat yeah but let me let me
tell you something and I hope you'll
take this as a compliment he was like
the atomic clock and
Boulder it was exactly 40
seconds no I mean literally I used to
boil I used to boil an egg to him
no he he'd hear the noises start
he' check his watch i' call it 35
seconds he'd say give me 4 seconds I
mean it was amazing so you know if I
rumor someone that took two hours I'd
probably be thinner you start
that